welcome professor Fergusson thank you so
much for doing this for us to be here so
this is the first of a two book
authorized biography and in your preface
you say that quote not only has this
book been written with Henry Kissinger
cooperation was written at his
suggestion had that happened well I'm a
little nervous of the word authorised I
suppose authors ought to be nervous of
it because it implies that he had some
control over it but when he suggested
this to me which is now more than 10
years ago
I said yes I will be do willing to do
this part are on condition I have a
completely free hand you have to kind of
accept that if you ask me to do this you
give me access to your private papers I
will write what I I think is the truth
which was incidentally the basis on
which I'd written the previous book
mystery of the lost child family so he
agreed to that and that says it's not
authorized because there's lots of it
that he doesn't like some good and I
think I think I would wouldn't have
taken it on on any other basis so how
does it happened I mean did you know him
beforehand how did you find you what was
the moment when you got him of course
but I met it by clicking new of you he
can read my stuff we met at a party in
London I tell this story in the preface
and the spirit of full disclosure and
and we were talking about one of the
books that I had written about the first
world war the pity of warning read it
and we're having a conversation about
that and so we met on that basis and I
forget exactly when but sometime after
that the subject came up I think he was
attracted to the idea of a scholarly
biography being written I wasn't the
first person that had been considered
for this job but when he put the
question to me I did that around and
actually initially said no and he then
wrote me a very Henry Kissinger letter a
good letter or an email it was a lesson
he didn't do he know and the letter said
would affect what a great shame just
when I had decided you were the ideal
man to to do this and just as I had
found 150 boxes of my private papers
that had been that I had thought were
lost I'm afraid I was hooked because I I
suppose just a week or two later was
looking at those boxes of papers once I
started looking at the stuff I decided I
should do it I've been a bit daunted of
one because it is an extremely difficult
life to write for a range of reasons
it's controversial it's very well
documented it's just a difficult thing
to do but once I started to read these
these papers particularly bit early
correspondence and diary extracts within
a few hours I thought well I really have
to take this on so this is not a man who
has been undocumented and he's written
its own memoirs extensively even longer
than your book yes 3 my boy yes so why
do you think he wanted and he's also
shared some information he spoke with
Walter Isaacson for his biography why do
you think he wanted this book written
well one of the points I make in the
book is that he is by training a
historian and a historian knows that the
memoirs are different from the histories
from the biographies his three volumes
after all cover mostly his time and
government was really mixed to nothing
about the period before 1969 and so
there was half of his life in effect
that he hadn't written about it and that
in fact that said relatively little
about what Isaacson's book which is is
very good is essentially a journalist
book based mostly on interviews and
really relatively few documents there
and I think the idea was well somebody
should write a scholarly biography based
on the documents on the archival sources
because that simply didn't exist and
although there are a whole bunch of
books that you can find in libraries
that purport to be
biographies of Kissinger most of them
are not really based on terribly much
more than than hearsay so I think the
argument for a scholarly biography of a
major figure in modern
American history was a compelling one
and as it turns out the material was
very good very rich and I was lucky
because that whole period really from
his earliest days growing up in Germany
right down to the moment Richard Nixon
offered him the job of national security
advisor in late 1968 had largely been
neglected by previous writers you were
often described as a conservative
historian do you think he chose you in
part for that reason with the other
unnamed person who we offered it to also
a conservative historian yes he was I
think it's more important that I'm
British though because I think there's
some advantage to being an outsider in
writing a work of American history oddly
enough one characteristic feature of
Henry Kissinger's life has been the
extraordinary political controversy that
can be dated like the early 1970s and
has raged on more or less incessantly
ever since and in some ways the
controversies are of the generation of
1968 of the generation that came of age
during the Vietnam War and I'm your
generation a new generation Americans
I'm I'm somebody who can come at this as
history I don't have memorabilia from
Woodstock in my attic I think that's
that's important on the question of
conservatism I think it's worth maybe
adding a footnote because conservative
means something different if you have
grown up in the UK it's not
republicanism the US version and I'm not
by any means a Republican in my in my
politics now that I live in the United
States I'm a conservative in either the
way that enemy Kissinger was a
conservative as young academic I'm a
sort of European conservative and you
often feel like a liberal if you're a
European conservative in the United
States because things that American
conservatives say are so completely
shocking to you so in the same kind of
way that that
that Kissinger's conservatism is really
a European variant so is mine and that
may be one reason that he thought it
would work when you say a European
conservative and thinks that you find
shocking are they in the national
security realm or is it social issues
you know the social issues and though
those things that I regard is not being
in the domain of politics that are in
the domain of politics in the US on
national security issues it seems to
need it's often the case that people get
confused into thinking that there is
some kind of straight punch and Judy
show argument going on about national
security I've been critical in recent
years of President Obama I was also very
critical of his predecessor in the book
Colossus published in 2004 I was
extremely critical of the invasion of
Iraq and the way that the occupation was
handled so part of the reason for doing
this I suppose was that I had be drawn
into a debate about US foreign policy
from the moment really that I set foot
in the US and I probably approached it
rather naively thinking that I could
criticize both Republicans and Democrats
it's hard to be in that position you
inevitably are expected to be on one
side or the other but I think on
national security issues and on much
else I'm probably more independent I'm
not sure what there's no question that
there's been a convergence since the end
of the Cold War and if you look at
issues like Bosnia or Iraq itself that
there were people on the Left who saw
the humanitarian challenges with people
on the right who are isolationist that's
certainly true I'm not sure what an
independent is other than perhaps
somebody who should visit case-by-case
right or at least somebody recognizes
that there can't be a simple party line
on these national security issues and
somebody who doesn't want to be bound by
a party line on on social and cultural
issues
interestingly I found that Kissinger as
a young man was in rather the same
position that he thought of himself as a
small C conservative he certainly didn't
self identifies as a liberal in 1950s or
1960s Harvard but when he encountered
real American conservatives Barry
Goldwater's supporters at the 1964
Republican convention he was appalled
and he always had a very uneasy
relationship with the right of the
Republican Party in deep with the
neoconservatives as well
and that's not the interesting things
about Kissinger's predicament and it may
explain why it's a controversial figure
he has enemies on the left on things of
similar harsh and and then Christopher
Hitchens who really attacked him from
that but he always said as many enemies
on the right particularly in the debates
in the 1970s about whether they talked
with the Soviet Union was a sellout so
the book is called the idealist which is
a rather contrarian take on Kissinger
who is even in less kindly description
is described as the ultimate realist if
not a direct descendent of Machiavelli
so your choice of the word ideal is what
you explained in the book is really not
a
wilsonian notion of idealism it's more
of a country notion of idealism can you
explain for the audience at home what
you mean by idealist when it comes to
Kissinger and why it's our notion of
course traditionally is wilsonian ism
but that's really not the description
you're using it's true that most people
think of Henry Kissinger as the arch
realist and the names they throw around
are Machiavelli or Maximus Bismarck Viki
wrote about both metalic and Bismarck so
maybe it's not surprising that people
have fallen into that trap but I try to
show in the book that it's it is a trap
he really wasn't a realist that were
realists who argued that the United
States should simply follow follow its
narrow national self-interest that he
wasn't one of them and those like Hans
Morgenthau who
realists were often critical of him that
was the first clue that there was
something wrong with this Machiavellian
notion when I started to read his
writings firmly which I begin begin to
think not many people had done I was
really struck by something but they were
in fact critical or realism the book
about the Congress of Vienna award
restored it's very critical of Matheny
the things essay on is not the White
Revolution is highly critical of the
maestro of nineteenth-century
realpolitik so I started to think
something funny here and then I delve
deeper into kissinger's intellectual
development and three things are really
striking one he's an experienced growing
up in the twenties and thirties and
driven to flee Germany in 1938 made him
not surprisingly highly critical of
appeasement of the foreign policy of
appeasement of the dictators what he
characterizes the appears as realists
and a very interesting essay because
they thought they were pursuing the kind
of narrow self-interested approach to
foreign policy and disregarded the human
rights abuses of the dictatorship so
number one his own experience in the
1930s makes him suspicious of what he
saw as the realist appeasers number two
can't he comes to Harvard and to try and
get rid of this rather pushy
undergraduate William yandel Eliot
professor of government says effectively
go away and read Immanuel Kant and come
back when you're finished expecting
never to see him again an under
estimating Kissinger who did indeed go
off and read a vast amount of Carnes
writing and put it into his ultimately
put it into his senior thesis he was
deeply influenced by his reading of Kant
particularly in the problem that on the
one hand Kant tells us there is such a
thing as freedom free will free choice
but the experience of freedom is real
but on the other hand can argue is that
there is some kind of plan for the world
for Humanity leading ultimately to
perpetual peace and the central
discussion in
senior thesis is whether there's a way
of reconciling these two positions and
he concludes that there is and
ultimately the experience of choices is
a real one and freedom as Kissinger
defines it is this inner experience it's
an intellectual or cerebral experience
the third point which is perhaps the
crucial one given the Cold War context
of his early academic career was it
Kissinger rejected materialism he was an
idealist in the sense that he rejected
materialist theories of history like
Marxism Leninism the theory of the
Soviet bloc also he rejected capitalist
materials theories of the sort that said
if our growth rate is higher than their
growth rate then we'll win the Cold War
all Rostow was a an experience of this
kind of materialism so I think on those
three counts Kissinger emerges as an
idealist something like an oddity a
rarity in the Harvard of the month of
the 1950s but I think it's what made his
contribution fundamentally distinctive
and made him stand out from the pack of
people who thought that you could solve
the Cold War with systems analysis or
something of that sort although you have
many quotes in the book that make him
sound as if he is an idealist and
certainly someone who is horrified by
the appeaser is someone who believes
that the u.s. is more likely to win on
ideals than Don said on materialist
issues at the same time his writing
other biographies are filled with you
know pretty brutal rail policy quotes as
well from him I noticed in Walter
Isaacson's biography quotes Kissinger is
pushing back in the early 1970s against
the idea of pressuring Pakistan to be
less repressive asking why is it our
business how they govern themselves that
doesn't sound like an idealist to me he
defends cutting off aid to the Kurds in
Iraq saying covert action should not be
confused as missionary work this is the
sort of that doesn't sound to me like an
idealist I mean someone who doesn't feel
that the US has to be defending human
or pressing allies because of their
repressive nature
well the two answers to that one is that
you're really talking about volume 2
which I haven't written yet and there's
no telling what the subtitle will be but
it's not likely to be the idealist let's
put it that way and I'm a little
cautious about talking about that later
period since I am frankly stood in the
midst of doing the research and I tend
not to really make up my mind until I
plowed through a lot of documents and
thought a lot about it so it's early
days to be talking about the 1970s for
me I think the most I could I could risk
saying secondly in response is that we
can't really understand what Kissinger
and for that matter Nixon and Ford the
presidents he served were trying to
achieve if we just look at isolated
cases and throw up our hands and say how
shocking and callous because these
isolated countries these particular
instances that you mentioned have to be
seen as part of a grand strategy and
most books that are highly critical of
Kissinger tend to focus on a particular
issue and disregard the strategic
framework the strategic framework is as
Kissinger says in his early writings
something that imposes a hierarchy if
your primary goal is to avoid World War
three and seek some kind of
accommodation through day talk with the
Soviet Union then there may be other
things that are pawns on the chessboard
that you have to sacrifice to that end
if your second goal is to use an opening
to China to put pressure on the Soviets
then for the sake of that you may have
to make compromises would say the
Pakistani government that if you had no
other concerns you might not make so I
think any judgment that you make about
foreign policy has to be done not on a
case-by-case basis but in a strategic
framework in his early writing and this
I do talk about in the book Kissinger
says it is the nature of statesmanship
that you have to make choices and you're
free to make these choices but they're
really very frequently choices between
evils and the challenge is to try to
decide what the less
of two evils is and Kissinger says this
is their right from the very earliest
writing that's the problem that's the
challenge even the tragedy of the
Statesman that there are sometimes no
good options there are just evils that
you have to choose between all that is
persuasive but I would put that in the
real politic camp in the sense of seeker
you know seeking stability from the sake
of peace were not annihilation but
having to look the other way on the
repression in Pakistan or his decision
or joint decision for the bombing of
Cambodia or something that you mean you
do engage some of this in the book his
role in Chile he himself has suggested
that before
while he's denied that he engineered the
coup that he certainly supported the
idea that even one eye and a in there
you know these are transcendent things
that sound like real politic to me and
they are the reasons why he is so
controversial itself one of the things
that I do at the end of volume one end
in effect in January 1969 is to imply
that there is question for volume two
and the question is does he remain an
idealist
does he adhere to the principles that he
set out as an intellectual and a
frequent critic of u.s. foreign policy
or did the experience of government
change him into a realist and that
question I have yet to answer but it's
clearly central to the volume 2 volume 2
of this biography this biography the
first volume covers are the first half
of his life and in that period although
he was involved in government for
example as a an advisor to Kennedy was
mostly a and it's actually was mostly a
writer of books and articles and I think
it's it's fascinating to study him as an
intellectual to imagine if you like that
he was hit by a bus in January 1969 this
book would still have been possible the
second owners are complaining
well I'm not sure about that because it
seems to me that the intellectual
contribution was really quite a
substantial one at a time when
international relations become more and
more divorced in history but in the
Academy and debates perhaps becoming
even more so since then Kissinger argued
you have to have historical framework
history is two nations what character is
two individuals if you don't know the
history you won't understand the
counterparties I think that was a very
important insight that still resonates
today we'll think of that central
problem that he defines the problem of
conjecture which I think gets to the
heart of some of the questions you're
raising Kissinger says not only you have
to choose between evils but when you
make the choice you don't really know
how things are going to turn out you may
take a difficult preemptive action and
avert disaster here he has in mind 1938
but if you're successful and you avert
World War two is anybody grateful no
because it didn't happen and in
international relations in foreign
policy there's this great asymmetry but
a successful costly early decision may
get you no payoffs
because in pre-empting disaster you you
basically prevent it from happening and
therefore you prevent people from
suffering it if you play for time
kissing the armies you may get lucky and
then people will think you'd remember
Slee wise and if you are not lucky in
things turn out badly
you can always say well I you know I did
my best so that the temptation is as we
say these days to kick the can down the
road when you come to assess any of the
decisions that were taking after 1960 a
queen was actually in a position to
advise the decision-maker the president
you have to ask yourself not only well
how does this fit into the grand
strategy but also the question at the
time the decision was taken was this the
right decision at the time could you say
with certainty or with confidence not
with certainty this is the lesser evil
of any two courses of action that's the
challenge I've set myself in trying to
assess his work and the second one so as
he said the book begins with his
childhood in German
and you note several times what
Kissinger plays down the impact on his
worldview of that childhood and the fact
a matter that he lost many friends and
many members of his family to the
Holocaust and you quote a 2007 interview
with him when he says my first political
experiences were as a member of a
persecuted Jewish minority many members
of my family and about 70% of the people
I went to school with died in
concentration camps so that is not
something I can forget I do not agree
with the view that analyzes everything
in terms of my alleged Jewish origin I
have not thought of myself in those
terms what's going on there I mean I'm a
Jewish American and a lot of my
attitudes toward Mike are what goes on
in the world
repression extremism as well as my
notion of American responsibility to try
and fix things comes I believe out of
that past and I certainly didn't live
through the Holocaust so what's going on
there and I would say this alleged
Jewish origin is also a rather sort of
disturbing one what do you think is
happening with him well I've tried in
the book to tell the story as accurately
as I can and it is a remarkable one
although not a unique one by any means
he grew up in a part of Germany where
Nazism was particularly violent bank
owning passive of the very next to
Nuremberg and little ton of foot as he
grew up became a teenager the Nazi
regime came to power and his rights were
whittled away just as his parents were
until the point was reached that they
had to flee when he came back six years
after leaving in a US Army uniform he
witnessed the liberation of a
concentration camp outside Hanover at
Arnhem and then discovered after the war
was over that nearly all those family
members who had not left Germany had
died including his grandmother so
clearly these were searing experiences
and I think the reason that he suffered
to Quincy sought to downplay them was
the tendency of maybe earlier writers to
ascribe so much importance to those
events that his subsequent development
was a kind of response to trauma and
he's very clear in the letters that he
writes home to his parents in the late
1940s and the things that he writes
about the war experience that he's not
traumatized it's something that he
explicitly says and I think we need to
understand that the war experience was
not quite as we might imagine it those
of us who were too young to experience
it for example I think it's very it's
very striking that he writes this short
essay the eternal June really I think
for his own use to record the experience
after seeing the liberation of the Arlen
concentration cabinets addressed to one
of the Polish inmates of the camp and
it's a remarkable document which I I
reap reducing for because I think it
captures how searing the experience the
witnessing of the Holocaust had been at
the same time the war changed him in a
very important way it had destroyed his
religious faith and he and his younger
brother had to confront their parents in
particularly they're devout the Orthodox
father with this change
Kissinger writes very openly I am
different this has changed me this
experience this exposure not just of the
Holocaust but to the war has made me
fundamentally different and I no longer
can really believe in what you brought
me up to believe so that moment is a
profoundly important on the loss of
religious faith and I think it explains
some of the vivid ins with which he
subsequently discussed his Jewishness
Henry Kissinger is a man who identifies
as a Jew but is not a believer there's
not an observant Jew that's by no means
an unusual particular but I think what I
try to do in the book is
show how he arrived in that position
after the Orthodox upbringing that he
had in South Germany and these
extraordinary experiences that he had
during the war being a believer is
different from being Orthodox for any
religion of duty are you suggesting that
he is no no longer believed that God
existed because of the experience in
Germany well that's not something that's
entirely explicit enough anything that
he has said and I'm mr. Reagan when I go
to the core idealism as well and believe
that if you notice when two men on was
not writing to his birth saying I'm a
reformed on like I'm changing synagogue
that was definitely not a message and
and he he did not subsequently he can
practice two days so in that in that
sense I think it was a complete loss of
mood to space but not something that led
him to deny his his Jewishness thus it's
not as if he was looking to convert to
Christianity on the contrary Henry
Kissinger is a Jew but he's not a
believer nothing that's an important
consequence of the war experience and
it's unusual that it's a well documented
but he wrote very frankly to his parents
about what this meant for the rest of
his life so believer and idealism don't
those two things relate to each other in
some way well what's clear is that if
you are steeped in and licensed for
enlightenment philosophy as Kissinger
was read your ways we can't you don't
necessarily subscribe to a traditional
deity though you may acknowledge the
possibility of the Supreme Being and an
ultimate divine or providential purpose
but Kissinger is more much more
interested in the experience of freedom
of choice the individual experience of
freedom many years in the possibility of
the an all-knowing deity that plays very
little very little role in his
subsequent thought
so to move that from that notion of one
heart to another one of the things that
I hadn't realized is he really made his
name and became something of a rock star
as a reasonably young age by writing
about nuclear weapons and being a strong
advocate of this concept of limited war
the limited use of nuclear weapons you
go out of your way to say that he was
not the model for dr. Strangelove a--
that was instead Herman Kahn but there
is something damn strange Le'Veon about
the idea that you could have the limited
use of nuclear weapons without it
spiraling out of control
you know what will drove him to think
that and why do you think it made him so
popular at that point it seemed now
people would think that he was pretty
crazed well first of all you got to
imagine an encounter in Harvard Yard on
his friend and liberal Arthur
Schlesinger jr. essentially introduces
Kissinger to a big debate that is going
on about the strategy of the Eisenhower
administration Eisenhower's concept was
that you had to threat massive
retaliation to deter the Soviets from
expansion and it was very binary you are
the blew up the world or you accepted
the move is tolerable the debate was
whether there could be any middle
position or whether US strategy had had
shrunk to this all-or-nothing strategy
which implied brinksmanship which
implied risking Armageddon every time
you wanted to resist a Soviet move
around the world on the basis of a
conversation in Harvard Yard Kissinger
jots down some thoughts and on this
question
these impress says enjoy they impress
other people who see them and he's
gradually drawn away from the study of
19th century diplomacy which is what
he'd written his PhD about and into
these contemporary debates about nuclear
strategy and he begins to partly in
discussions at the Council on Foreign
Relations with far more experienced
strategic thinkers it didn't to think
about the unthinkable question could you
use nuclear weapons in a limited way
and avoid full-scale Armageddon now when
you put it like that it does sound like
dr. Strangelove legitimizing the the use
of the most destructive weapon that had
ever been devised a little teeny nuclear
war right and that's how he tries to
make the case in nuclear weapons and
foreign policy that you can have limited
tactical nuclear exchanges that won't
escalate to full-blown Armageddon two
interesting things one he later reversed
that position and came to the conclusion
that you couldn't be sure it wouldn't
escalate so he did a kind of
intellectual flip-flop or u-turn on that
key question that was after the book had
made him famous the book arrives at a
critical moment in Cold War history
Sputnik has just been launched it's 1957
Americans are beginning to think that
the Soviets have not only caught up with
them but overtaken them and along comes
this book by a dynamic new thinker who
argues there's a way of dealing with
this problem that won't blow the world
to smithereens
key point to notice that is often
overlooked is that although Kissinger
himself pulled back from the idea of
limited nuclear war the US military did
not and lauded the Soviet military and
nor for that matter did any of the NATO
countries because from that point on
strategy in the Cold War assumed the
possibility of unlimited nuclear war it
became the basis for NATO's plans to
defend Western Europe from a Soviet
invasion that's what all those tactical
so-called battlefield nuclear weapons
were for that's why the superpowers
didn't just have intercontinental
ballistic missiles they also had
intermediate and tactical weapons too so
I think a key point that I try to make
in the book is that although Kissinger
himself was ambivalent about the
intellectual breakthrough the idea of a
limited nuclear war in practice it
became doctrine for the militaries on
both sides of the Cold War and just
because it didn't happen
just because there never was a limited
nuclear war but doesn't mean that it was
science fiction and in fact to this day
it is a perfectly real possibility and
it's resurfaced in the most recent
debates about how how Europe and NATO
respond to to further Soviet aggression
in Eastern Europe so it's an idea that
has not gone away at all and all of the
weapons are you suggesting that there
are serious makers in Europe now who
would advocate for the limited use of
the use of tactical nukes and if the
Russians were just decide to roll in or
send little green men into into one of
the balls nobody's writing op-eds about
this but the weapons exist and if they
exist there may be a rack must be a
rationale for not this is very very
limited narrower than if you recall the
beginnings of Bush 43 and negotiations
with the Soviets and all that was very
focused on pulling our tactical nerve
right the nuclear arsenals are smaller
than they were but they haven't
disappeared nor has the theory
disappeared it's actually smaller on the
American side we don't know what the
Russians have they remind also that
because there's been significant
proliferation since
Kissinger's heyday the possibility of a
limited nuclear war involving a smaller
nuclear power with another smaller
nuclear powers probably it's more likely
now than it was then when essentially
there were superpower monopolies on
nuclear capability so I think this was
an important contribution to the debate
and it's not too surprising that it may
design because in a sense he beat other
strategic thinkers to the insight that
these weapons could be at least their
use could be credibly threatened and
that's the point if the weapons exist
and they existed really for the rest of
the Cold War
then the rationale for them can't have
been wholly observes and certainly not
as absurd as the movie dr. Strangelove
so
Berlin he had very strong opinions about
Berlin and how it's handled it when the
wall goes up but he doesn't seem to be
unless I've misread this advocating the
use of of tactical nuclear weapons on
what is pretty much a frontline issue
far more important than Cuba far more
important than many other things that
are going on well is anything when the
Berlin crisis comes to a head and tanks
US and Soviet tanks are facing one
another in central Berlin Kissinger's
hawkish and he is arguing for a tougher
line and ultimately Kennedy took Kennedy
ultimately says a wall is better than a
war and allows the Berlin question to be
solved by the building of the war he
doesn't say we should be ready to use
nuclear weapons over this issue and it's
got interesting
he he is deeply worried that the
military may take it upon themselves to
use them if there are not sufficiently
clear lines of command from the White
House that becomes a big issue in the
1964 election because Goldwater who
really was quite reckless in the way
that he talks about nuclear weapons
seemed ready to give to delegate the
authority to use these kinds of weapons
to commanders in the field and Christmas
is very opposed to that
so his positions are nuanced one and I
think that's another reason why he's not
dr. Strangelove having written the book
arguing for limited nuclear warfare
within a very short time he refutes the
virion admits that there's a risk of
escalation the old thing is that the
theory survives its authors repudiation
of it I naturally accept the notion of a
theory but it's part of military
doctrine now but well that for another
day it's certainly called a Russian
leadership talk for now I might want to
that's exactly why I was talking about
Americans the point I'm trying to make
is that in military circles this is by
no means ruled out and these weapons are
still in existence for a reason mr.
Putin made it very clear in his
interview with chai rose just the other
night that its nuclear weapons that a
part of the reason he wields power it's
certainly not the
strength of the Russian economy well
that is certainly true but not necessary
but what will have the tactical new
conversation over a beer at some point
as President Obama would say I would
suggest perhaps and maybe I miss reading
this that the issue with Berlin was
either he had changed his mind or the
other part of his argument is that you
have to signal to the Soviets that we're
not looking for your complete surrender
we're not looking for your obliteration
and if we were to use tactical nuclear
weapons it would have to be in a
sideshow war not in one that was on the
direct front line is that the right
reading potentially of for Berlin well
certainly in his writings in the 1950
and 60s he draws a distinction between a
battlefield in Central Europe in what
had been his native land and a
battlefield somewhere less populous like
say the Middle East so that's part of it
it was definitely difficult to imagine
how a war over Berlin could not escalate
given just how densely populated it was
and how many weapons there were in the
in the vicinity but I think the second
issue here and that is the question of
how do you solve the German the German
problem and it's interesting and this is
another part I think of the idealism
that Kissinger tends to be attracted to
the self-determination argument that we
associate with Woodrow Wilson earlier on
you dismissed the idea that could be any
real Sounion elements at all kiss mr.
Spock will guess what the central idea
of Woodrow Wilson number should be
national self-determination is there in
much that Kissinger writes about Germany
he sees German unification as desirable
it has to be in terms of democracy has
to be free votes
the Soviets can't rig it so that ends up
becoming just another greater East
Germany I think he's pretty clear about
that so through the debates about Berlin
there's no I think there's no appetite
for blowing Germany up for the sake of
of winning a strategic showdown
it isn't just close to a dinner the
German leader through much of the Cold
War and unsympathetic
to him but he gets written ervis when
some West German politicians like franz
josef strauß seem to what the Americans
to be engaged in brinksmanship over the
whole question of Berlin because some
West improvisation quite happy for
Germany to be divided they quite likes
getting rid of of East Germany not to
mention East Berlin that wasn't
Kissinger's view he ultimately has parts
he United and free Germany so he talked
just a little bit about his position
with the Kennedy administration he seems
to at one point hoped that he was going
to be brought into the inner circle then
blames Bundy for shoving him out how
much was that shared ideology how much
was he had just gotten to that point
when she was going to be be brought in
well it goes back to our earlier
conversation about kissinger's
conservatism but coffee soft
statesmanship and national security as
something that was above partisan
divisions he felt that he could
simultaneously advise Nelson Rockefeller
and then go and join the Kennedy
administration if asked just as later on
in the later 1960s with Rockefeller but
also talking to Humphrey and also
talking to Nixon I mean there's a Fenton
Kissinger's mind that there's a kind of
technocratic expertise that he has that
should be available to anybody who
happens to become President Kennedy is
you know was rounding out Harvard
professors as if intent on emptying
Cambridge informing his administration
and prior to his election he'd been in
touch with Kissinger and any other
people on the Harvard faculty they all
rushed down to Washington when the
administration was formed and the Dean
of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
McGeorge Bundy became the national
security adviser now this is when the
plot thickens because it seems as if
Kissinger is going to be involved but on
a part-time basis and at first I was
puzzled by this whole arrangement
why did you agree to be a part-time
consultant to the white house are your
Harvard classes so dear to you but it
turns out this is Bundy's suggestion
because Bundy quickly saw that Kissinger
was a potential rival because of you
after all a lot about the key issues at
the moment not Cuba but certainly Berlin
certainly nuclear strategy so I think
what happened was a kind of lesson in
Beltway politics for the young Kissinger
he discovered that as long as Bundy
could stop him having contact with the
president as long as he could kind of
shut him in a room and give him a bunch
of files we read those Bundy would say
and write a report but he never actually
got to see Kennedy more than a handful
of times he was out of the loop and he
had an intensely frustrating experience
nominally a consultant but hardly ever
in the presence of the president treated
by Bundy as an insider but in effect an
outsider with only limited access to the
key documents so this is the beginning
of what I'll call the political
education of Henry Kissinger be an
introduction to the dark arts of
Washington politics certainly one can
see certain foreshadowing from the way
he ends up basically cutting everybody
else are from Nixon in the White House
here's what an important subplot of the
book is is that this education leads to
a fairly sustained rethink of how the
national security apparatus should work
and pilot time 1968 69 comes around
Kissinger's written a whole series of
papers are co-authored in some cases a
whole series of papers about how in fact
the president should be advised what the
role of the National Security Council
should be fascinating really in the in
the sense I hope the book offers not
just a biography but a history of the
Cold War through that lens of biography
we see how this institutional evolution
progressed from the quite rigid
bureaucratic style of Eisenhower's
National Security Council really
military in its character and in it's
hierarchical rigidity but through the
more freewheeling Kennedy style to the
ultimate boozy lunch approach
of Lyndon Johnson the Tuesday lunch
sessions that produced so many
disastrous decisions by 1968 Kissinger
is not alone in thinking something is
pretty badly broken and so he spends a
lot of 1968 just thinking about how you
could better organize the system to
combine the best elements of
Eisenhower's National Security Council
with those things that had worked well
on the under Kennedy in a strong
National Security Adviser not
surprisingly Vance becomes a part of the
part of the recipe and you argue in the
book that those those reviews are big
reason why Nixon offers him the job and
you also devote a considerable amount of
time to rebutting the widely held notion
and it's not just Hitchens but also
Isaacson and others that during the 68
campaign Kissinger passed sort of
critical information to Nixon on the
Paris peace talks and that Nixon in turn
on about a bombing halt that Nixon and
in turn goes and tells us the South
Vietnamese they're going to get a better
deal and you rebut that and say that
give all let you rebut it you get you
come up with a series of explanations
for why that's not true
it seems it's critical part of the lore
and Henry Kissinger why is it wrong
oh yes the law which I think goes back
to similar goes like this the devious
Kissinger eager for power rats on the
Johnson administration by revealing a
closely guarded secret that Johnson's
people were about to do a deal with the
North Vietnamese that would bring peace
and this information allows Nixon to win
the election it falls apart actually on
close inspection this story for all
bunch of reasons one as I mentioned
earlier Kissinger had been involved in
trying to find a way out of the war in
Vietnam right through 1967 working with
the Johnson administration to try to
find some points of contact with the
North Vietnamese - as we mention already
he had
in the practice of offering his counsel
his advice to more than one party more
than one candidate so that's nothing too
surprising when the Nixon people
approached him as they did he gives them
the usual kind of well I can only tell
you this response that he previously
given Kennedy when Kennedy had
approached him so when one looks at it
simply from that vantage point we had
seen this movie before the second
critical point is there were no secrets
to betray because the negotiations were
clearly not really going anywhere and
the Paris peace talks were these public
talks
unlike the 1967 secret talks but it was
the first was right people said that was
the Johnson serious contemplation of a
bombing hold on a particular date which
was then going to bring the North
Vietnamese back remember he had been
halting the bombing repeatedly the
previous year - and Kissinger had been
involved in that process
tried to get the bombing pause are
thought to be long enough to get the the
intermedius from France to go to Hanoi
so this was nothing new and nor was it
entirely likely that it was going to
bring an immediate peace the critical
piece though is that you didn't need to
be Henry Kissinger with inside
information to know this was going on it
was clearly going on everybody
understood what Johnson's incentive was
politically not least the folk
Vietnamese the Nixon campaign had any
number of sources on what was going on
the idea that there was some
fantastically hot secret that Kissinger
was able to bring doesn't stand up to
close scrutiny Kissinger was in Paris he
knew Hammond the other negotiators
Holbrooke but I can't find any evidence
that there was something that Kissinger
knew that nobody else knew what is clear
is that Kissinger communicated his
analysis that the administration was
looking for a breakthrough the head of
the election but Nixon already knew that
and indeed it was more or less an open
secret so I find the idea that this was
a sort of reasonable dirty trick that
then got Kissinger the
National Security Adviser which is the
way the story ends
simply unsubstantiated by any
documentation that has survived of
course maybe there's a secret memorandum
has been destroyed that reveals this all
to be true but I find it implausible
since so much that Kissinger had done
the year before when he had been
accident in trying to find a way to end
the war in documented by him and by the
State Department they get really careful
paperwork of all these initiatives
towards the North Vietnamese there's
nothing to indicate that this was going
on in 1968 except for a few subsequent
interviews the most important of which
bye Nixon's National Security Advisor
Richard Allen is just full of sour
grapes because of course Allen was
subsequently in life by Kissinger and
excluded driven itíd effect of the of
the administration so I think the story
as I see it is is a great story maybe it
has what Stephen Colbert calls
truthiness
but it's not something you can document
and it doesn't it doesn't seem to me to
stand up to see the scholarly scrutiny
although Nixon writes in RM during the
last days of the campaign when Kissinger
was providing us with information about
the bombing halt when Kissinger was
providing us with information about the
bombing halt I became more aware of his
knowledge and influence this would
suggest that at least a there was
information going there about the
bombing halt and that it did raise his
profile with Richard Nixon well he was
communicating through Allen and other
people in the administration and Nixon
was seeking his counsel that's clear and
nobody's ever denied that but the notion
that the information was somehow
classified information that the
kissimmee was leaking I don't think can
be substantiated I think in your book
you do say that that Nixon worries at
one point that it's a trap that
Kissinger has been set up to pass him
information about Johnson's thinking
that that is going to be in traps who
Nix it up apparently valued this is even
though you you argue that if everybody
knows I think one of the confusions is
between analysis and intelligence you
know Kissinger is obviously offering his
analysis that's documenting setsize
because it says information that I don't
think this is information in the sense
of inside baseball information rather
than there wasn't he who the experts
like tell me I can find the Nixon quote
pointed morning I think the issue here
is that Disney was offering his advice
his analysis that's very clear that is
documented but what's not there is some
kind of smoking gun of a secret that
Kissinger was in a position to betray
because I don't in there was one so can
you translate a Kissinger ISM for me
several years back when I was still a
full-time journalist I was invited to a
small dinner I think as I recall Richard
Holbrooke was a key driver behind us may
he rest in peace was with a senior Iraqi
official and Kissinger was there and so
when it came time for the Q&A and being
the journalist that I am I asked a
question about what was the plan by the
Iraqis to finally make some sort of a
deal on oil revenues and before the
minister could even answer this question
Kissinger cut in and said that's a very
American question I don't think he said
that in a flattering way what did he
mean well you were there I wasn't can
you say you have the advantage of me
there but it perhaps is best on the
students alluding back to the view that
economics is not paramount when we were
discussing earlier Kissinger's idealism
I contrasted it with the materialism
which was much more commonplace and in
his generation of Americans a sense that
ultimately it's about economics and
capitalism is going to be communism on
the economics Kissinger never believed
that he made the argument that the Cold
War would not be won by differentials
and growth rates it would ultimately be
won by the belief that democracy was a
more attractive system than communism so
I think throughout his career Kissinger
has tended to be skeptical about
economics
lism of any sort arguments that
economics to before he tends to be
dismissive of that not always perhaps
rightly one of the interesting things to
address in volume 2 is the impact of the
oil shock in 1973 which most previous
scholars think that Christians are
greatly underestimated I think it's
certainly a leitmotif of his career to
be skeptical of of arguments that regard
economics as as the dominant force in
international affairs so when he was
suggesting I was a Material Girl if I
were to what you're saying else would be
odd for a man it's odd for a man it was
a secretary of state national security
advisor to use the word American was
something of an episode though but you
must've noticed in Volume one how often
he's critical of the way Americans do
think yeah was that argument he makes
that lawyers are playing much too big a
part in in policymaking and lawyers
dreadful at strategy because they do
everything on a case-by-case basis are
all the argument that he pretty mates
with Americans don't think history is
relevant that systems analysis or game
theory or some fancy new piece of social
science will solve a problem so I think
there is a distance a kind of critical
distance between Christie intellectually
and what he would regard as the American
inheritance skepticism about history a
legalism a tendency to put lawyers and
kakhi decision-making posts that's that
in there since the 1960s
so how thin-skinned to say I know did
you know in the book you have
communication he sends to Schlessinger
again to Arthur Schlessinger about how
he's being shoved out by bundy and and
how he wants to quit and it sounds
sounds almost petulant whining yes I
mean is he a very thin-skinned man well
the kitchens are in volume one is
certainly somewhat insecure and even in
academic politics is given to cries of
pain when he's not getting promoted as
he hopes he will be I think part of what
I said that to do in this book is to is
to show those sides of his personality
not all of which are very flattering and
maybe it's a marker of
the thinness of his skin today that he
didn't feel at all comfortable about
some of those passages it's it's
certainly not an authorized biography in
that sense because I think I've given
the subject a good deal to gnash his
teeth about it I was are in two minds
about whether to use a letter that you
wrote to to a girl when he was a
teenager that kind of really awfully
embarrassing cringe inducing letter that
I certainly wrote when I was a teenager
but it seemed to me to help us get to
the man and part of the problem about
writing about Henry Kissinger is that
there is this demonic figure created by
writers like Hirsch and and Hitchens who
is a kind of evil genius
so kind of dr. evil figure who commits
more crimes with Blee relishing every
death I mean this caricature monster
figure it is something is to get past if
you were trying to write a serious
biography and way to do that I thought
was to reveal all the humanity including
the teenage angst including the neurotic
professor a part of the story that
thinness of skin is part of what drives
the man gives them the motivation makes
them work harder than this contemporary
part of this story is a story of a
relentless drive to get the books
written to get the articles out and then
a drive to try to be involved in the
Paula
making process I tried to make it clear
to the reader that far from being a kind
of evil genius who Machiavellian with
Machiavellian ruses get to the top of
the greasy pole yes he frequently
blunders and lots of of screw-ups with
the press for example and he just makes
a whole series of mistakes in early
press conferences I thought that was
awaited to demolish at least partly this
demonic dr. evil figure and shows
somebody who was actually more credible
real human being so final question you
get access to reams of documents letters
including teenage letters teenage honest
letters and things of that sort but you
also interviewed kiss and you're
extensively unless I'm missing you don't
quote from him in the book I do yeah
they're quite a few quotes from the
interviews which are fit nated an
interview with author but relative to
the documents the interviews account for
a really small percentage of the total
source material it's probably not much
more than 1% so they were important as
background to me and I interviewed him
not only for this for him but so the
second volume so I have a lot of that
material still to use in fact I think
the bulk of the interviews that I
recorded relate to the period after 1968
and so in that sense they're still in my
my locker
so was he gnashing his teeth at what he
what he knows of what you've written
well I think anybody who sees they're
particularly their young life rendered
with I hope maximum accuracy on the page
can be a little taken aback one forgets
things that then turn up in the hands of
a historian so it's not I think an easy
process but not I think you've probably
quite normal if I had to read a book
about my first 46 years I would think I
would be lying on the floor cringing
between every page
next project I can type like this very
dull it said I don't think not
everything I recommend much much less
interesting so it's the title for the
next book the realist you might infer
that from the way that I conclude but I
haven't made up my mind and that's the
question that's the question I ask
myself every morning am I going to be
telling the story of a kind of evolution
away from idealism or is that not what
the real story is I don't know part of
the fun of writing history is that you
don't start with tremendously strong
theory you start the question and you
kind of want to be proved wrong I was
originally going to call this book
American Machiavelli when I was first
writing good proposals and I realized
within about a day that that was
completely wrong so part of the pleasure
of writing a life is that you will
constantly surprised by what the
documents tell you in that sense I have
no clue what the what the subtitle of
volume 2 will be thank you